a civil liberties lawyer told me
in washington d.c once that if you don't
have civil liberties you don't have
anything everything
starts from civil liberties well we know
or at least we should know that there
have been continuous attacks on civil
liberties of
americans ever since the nation started
and it's gotten worse over the years as
senate investigations have indicated
we have an expert on this chip burleigh
who's an investigator and
member of the nationals lawyers guild
he's also a writer who's written
extensively on
civil liberties in the united states and
attacks on them and also
into looking into the nature of the
fascist and nazi
right-wing elements of our society and
how they actually
work into the republican party and even
the white house
so this is going to be very revealing
and interesting program on alternative
views
chip has written articles in the covert
action information bulletin matter of
fact we presented some of these to you
he's also had material printed in the
nation
in chicago sometimes and the boston
globe
well you've really done a lot of
research
on this right-wing fascist nazi network
which sounds like strange thing why
would there be such a thing in the
united states
well what i've researched is in fact
that there are separate
categories like you just mentioned and
where they work together
because there's a difference between a
right winger or a reactionary
or a neo-nazi or a fascist or religious
fundamentalist
there's a number of different
authoritarian minded sectors in the
american body politic
and at various times they form
coalitions and work together
in political campaigns around certain
social political issues around
legislation
and the question then for me has been to
unravel those networks and try and
understand
why they see a common cause at any
different time around a particular issue
and why they're willing to work together
i work for
a think tank called political research
associates and
my background is as a paralegal
investigator which is a fancy term for a
snoop i
i research files i talk to people on the
phone
and what i try and piece together is the
ideology
of repression why repression is seen as
a good thing by people
on the political right in some cases and
not always
and there are conservatives who are
afraid of the bad aspects of repression
and fight it as hard as liberals and
progressives and radicals would
but there is in america a reactionary
core
of individuals who have been around for
a long time and in different historical
periods take on different
characteristics and today they are found
primarily in what's generally called the
new right
uh as well in the more extreme elements
would be found in the neo-nazi and
ku klux klan posse comatatus and
aryan nations crowd but they're distinct
and they're different and
it's important to make those
distinctions to understand the
connections
for instance there's very little
connection directly between groups such
as the ku klux klan and
aryan nations directly into republican
party politics
but there are direct connections for
instance between actual convicted nazi
collaborators from world war ii
and the republican party and and some
people couldn't understand why you would
have one and not the other but in fact
that's generally the case
chip since world war ii at least one of
the common denominators
of these right-wing groups has been
anti-communism yes
that is what justifies the repression of
people
deemed to be communist or subversive
has this been the result of your
research have you
found an anti-communist uh sure thread
running through these different groups
it's it's an anti-communist thread
that's very consistent
uh consistent actually all the way back
to the bolshevik revolution and
the fear of radicalism and if you look
historically like at the palmer raids
and then again at the red scare of the
50s
and then again at the political
repression that the fbi launched under
the cointelpro program
you see the fear of radicalism and of
bolshevism
time and time again being articulated
but i think it's important to understand
that it's
not a fear of real radicalism or real
communism or real socialism or real
subversion
it's it's what frank donner in the age
of surveillance calls a menikian
construct it's
it's a paranoid hyperbolic
fear of what is perceived to be
communist and if you look at how the
radical right in america
describes communism you come to
understand that they're really not
talking about
communism as it exists in any social
system
geographically around the world but this
hyperbolic and paranoid subversive red
network which is actually the name of
course of one of the red baiting
publications or red
channels or you know uh the birch
society is famous for putting out its
publications about this this complex
network of subversion
and so it's important to understand that
it's not real communism that's the fear
it's a perception of what is believed to
be
absolutely and why that's important is
as you see the
some of the authoritarian style leninist
regimes collapse
some of the excuse for fighting
communism obviously
collapses with it and yet you don't see
any diminution of
of repressive forces real communism was
never the issue it was the perception
so with the decline of real communism as
we know it in geographic terms
they're simply going to shift to new
scapegoats and that obviously we can see
that happening all
already with the drug war and terrorism
used as a rubric uh but also
other avenues there's an increase for
instance in the fear of what's called
satanism
which is there's always these things are
based on one little shred of reality
there are satanic cults in the world
however
every time you see a dead animal on the
road it's not the victim of a satanic
you know
disembowelment and yet there are people
who put out whole studies on
the spread of satanic culture through
american high schools where there is no
such thing
but you can perceive the hyperbolic
reality and react to it as if it were
real
so you're going to see the problem of
people are going to be surprised and
they shouldn't be when
when real communism around the world
changes its character
the repressive apparatus isn't going to
miss a step it's just going to come up
with
new new enemies to because it never
really was focused on real communism as
an issue but
part of love is used on social control
to keep down
excuse to keep down any change against
the existing order
uh let's be specific now and talk about
some of the people in the organization
in the radical right we'll forget about
the you know right-wing fringes the the
uh
clan and the aryan nations and the uh
white
uh uh the war yeah white areas yeah
right there and resistance
because they're not directly plugged in
in high political places or in that
attached to that intelligence services
right
like these other groups they're so more
important because can you tell us about
some of those
well i would point out that people like
tom metzger and pastor bob miles and
pastor uh
butler and others they interact with a
moo a mood that's set by electoral
politicians
clan members that reach the electoral
sure and that they feed off of each
other
and and that's important to understand
but there's not as direct a connection
as there was with with elements of the
radical right
uh one of the authors who works with us
is russ bellant of detroit right
and he's written several studies of this
network um
and it sounds pretty crazed to stand up
and say that you know
that the republican party for 20 years
has worked with nazi collaborators and
people who agree with that form of
political viewpoint
there are whole books written about how
after world war ii
the oss directly recruited the galen spy
network of the nazi apparatus in the
east
to help set up the cia that's not a
disputed matter of history
galen himself wrote about it it's been
written about in very very
mainstream texts in fact i did some
primary research on this i did a book on
herbert marcuza
who was in charge of the central europe
bureau of the state department
and after the war he was seeing the
resurrection of neo-nazi
groups and he did a research report on
this galen
thing there was all kinds not just the
galen ring all kinds of nazi rings
were recruited for u.s government
purposes money
were allowed passage to the u.s or latin
america etc so this has been absolutely
documented and what's interesting is
how that passage occurred through
refugee committees in many cases
and that a lot of these people who
weren't directly affiliated with the
german nazi apparatus were affiliated
with nazis supporting
eastern european countries political
systems that were pro-nazi at the time
partly because they wanted to have their
own national status but partly because
they believed it
and it's interesting to watch now in
eastern europe some of the people who
many years ago who are now in their 70s
who were brought over as part of this
anti-communist network
that was going to retake eastern europe
the captive nation so-called
are now involved in actually helping
provide funding for so-called democratic
forces
in emerging democratic eastern europe
and in fact what these are
are neo-fascist neo-nazi or old-fascist
old nazi networks
that supported a very feudal
authoritarian political structure
for the ukraine for romania for latvia
for lithuania
for estonia for many of these countries
and the
tragic joke is that the individuals who
were involved
in the holocaust directly and in
supporting nazi ideology
now are uh considered freedom fighters
and
pro-democratic advisors in these very
same countries
where they their hands were bloodied to
40 years ago okay now here are some of
the people who are some of the
organizations well the name one person
right out is my my favorite convicted
nazi collaborator active in the
republican party
is mr lazlo pasteur who i've interviewed
a number of times
and who lies to me every time i
interview and i
i say that because i've talked to him
and each time i go back
after hearing his excuses to the library
of congress primarily
and i research what he says and they're
just outright lies
that's a very well worn technique with
nazis is the big lie
he was a hungarian he is a hungarian
national who was an active member of the
hungarian aerocross
which was recently popularized in the
movie music box
it was a pro-nazi anti-semitic
fascist organization that wanted to
racially purify hungary
he claims that he was forced to join the
youth group
we discovered that he was in fact
appointed the director of the youth
group
each time you confront him he falls back
on a new position of lying
finally professor randolph braham of new
york went and obtained
his actual hungarian conviction record
and translated it
so that we could finally put to an end
his denials
he was convicted of being a nazi
collaborator by a hungarian court
prior to the communists taking over if
that matters to someone
he always said that the communists
jailed him and he was a freedom fighter
in fact while hungary was a multi-party
state in the
mid-40s he was convicted by his fellow
countrymen
in a pluralistic and open society and
did time he was in fact released under a
communist government
who felt that he had served enough time
that he had been sentenced for under the
previous government
how did he how did he get over here and
uh it's a little murky how he
exactly got over here he was freed in
hungary in the late 40s
sometime in the early 50s he shows up in
the united states
and he begins to immediately organize
republican party
ethnic hungarian units and then he
claims quite directly and there's no
reason to doubt him that
he worked out a deal with richard nixon
that uh he would
be part of a permanent ethnic outreach
apparatus of the republican party
that in fact happened george bush when
he was head of the republican party
reviewed lazlor pastor's
yearly plan for that organization called
the republican heritage groups council
and signed off on it and made
recommendations
and yet when it was exposed that azdo
pastor was actively working his campaign
he denied any knowledge of mr pastor
even though he had previously approved
his work plan for the year
how did it come out that he had this
nazi pass well actually it came out
because a group of
hungarian republicans who were not nazis
and not fascists
were appalled that he had he was the
person that they had to go to
to work with the republican party and
you know they said things that well
we're conservative but he's a nazi you
know they didn't want to work with him
uh and so they exposed him to jack
anderson many years ago uh and
he has been exposed repeatedly over the
years and he just never goes away
he just keeps coming back well he's just
one of many they have he's just one of
many he's a good example
of bulgarian is on the same organization
with the same type of past yeah
romanian and whatever there's a number
of eastern european ethnics that
pastor was responsible for bringing into
the republican party it's important to
understand that
not all nationalists from eastern europe
supported fascist politics
and not all people from those ethnic
groups support
these fascist tendencies what has
happened however is the republican party
has allowed these fascists
and anti-semites and racists to be their
connection to these
uh ethnic communities let's just follow
pastor through to the end because he
played a
big role in george bush's campaign and
is now playing a role
in contact with hungarian groups in
hungary
that the us is giving big bucks to to
try to quote unquote promote
democracy and the question is are these
fascist groups
so let's go into the election first he
was a member of bush's
1988 ethnic heritage outreach program
coalition of american nationalities it
was called
there's this permanent structure called
the republican heritage groups council
and that exists now continuously
throughout
and every four years they spin off
essentially a
campaign arm for tax and political
purposes
and and pastor was involved in that
along with a number of the other people
from the heritage groups council
we along with washington jewish week
exposed once again
this reality and the bush campaign
simply lied they simply said that
everyone
first of all it wasn't true in any way
they'd all resigned well it was true
and we defy them to find a single era of
fact in our report
and uh in fact when the philadelphia
inquirer and the boston globe called
these people and asked if they had
resigned they all said no
they all said they'd never been
contacted so the media just rolled over
and played dead on that whole question
and as soon as the campaign was over
these people began to be brought back
into administrative kind of positions uh
within the republican party and
within the bush administration then we
find the national endowment for
democracy
in funding hungarian and czechoslovak
groups
has been giving money to its
i'll use the real term front groups that
it's created
to carry on counter insurgency and that
who does the translations for these
requests from the hungarian groups but
one
laszlo pastor who also makes
recommendations as to which group should
get the funding
so what you have is a convicted nazi
collaborator who has been exposed
who did never renounce this politics but
continued to organize among fascist
racists and anti-semitic circles
who is now a interlocutor for funds
heading towards hungary and
czechoslovakia that are our tax dollars
so we reach into our pocket and pay a
convicted nazi collaborator to build
democracy in hungary
i mean i think there's something wrong
there i it is just me you know this
national endowment for democracy uh you
remember we told you uh
in our background story on the uh
nicaraguan elections it was a national
endowment for democracy that organized
and
financed the uno opposition of the san
anistas
so they do this all over the world and
its government
money its tax money going to this
organization
and then like you said in your nation
article the national entitlement for the
for democracy gave four hundred thousand
dollars to
your buddy here well they gave 400 000
to hungary of which at least some
portion was
channeled by him through his
recommendations and
there are other organizations many which
get money and these people uh are are
involved in
so it's a whole network it just didn't
one just the organization
itself which is kind of a tail out to
the republican party they get involved
with a lot of foreign policy overt and
covert and they have connections with
the intelligence services sure
but this is all predicated on a decision
that was made after world war
ii which is that if you have to choose
between working with a fascist or
working with a communist
in a particular country for foreign
policy reason
you always choose the fascist if they're
anti-common as long as they're
anti-communist right
to show you how this is still working
here's a may 9th edition of the guardian
and it says there's a new coalition
called the national command
council to support the democracy
movements in the ussr
and lo and behold who's involved
you you've read about this i guess and
the
the uh they funnel money to uh the
people who are against the whom you know
the the
the conservative the conte the
capitalist types in the soviet union
they want to support it
sure but also the material political
functions for the national council
will be says uh set up in a
and worked out in a conference in prague
hosted by czechoslovak president
javo right and many of the people
involved in this
are part of the new right and it's
important to understand that
laszlo pasteur himself works in offices
provided for him by paul wyrick of the
free congress foundation
and the free congress foundation itself
is merely one of a triad of important
groups
in the political reactionary right
there's the free congress foundation
which really is the the uh the christian
equivalent of islamic fundamentalism in
this country
they network ultra right-wing christian
fundamentalists
uh there's a heritage foundation which
is really the legislative
kind of research think tank that
justifies anything that is
laissez-faire capitalism and then
there's a much more secretive group
called the council for national policy
which is where these people get together
and meet in secret and
this is a group when you call them and
ask if they've had their annual meeting
they will not even admit that they have
meetings much less whether or not their
annual one has occurred
sounded like the right-wing bilderberg
well they are in fact exactly that they
were set up to be a counter
weight to the bilderberger trilateralist
council on foreign relations uh kind of
world view
are there establishment politicians that
are part of this or is this more of
these right-wing fringe groups
that just develop position papers or
strategies well this is in fact a place
where these
both of those forces get together you
have former ku klux klan leaders
in this you have religious
fundamentalists you have segregationists
you also have elected government
officials and
you have people like ali north who gets
invited to join after he's exposed
but who worked with many of these people
along the way and people like general
stinglob gives their dresses
so this is sort of like a nexus of
reactionary thought in the u.s and again
i mean i don't think that the
bilderbergers or the trilateralists or
the council on foreign relations is some
kind of arcane conspiracy
it's people who have money and power
trying to perpetuate that
and they're doing it and they've got
them they've done a very good job yeah
and what you have here is the
reactionary right thing well you know we
need to do the same thing and these
people network pretty well we need to
network each other
and so you have this triad of groups and
inside this triad of groups is
the ideological base for some of these
phenomena like
a convicted nazi collaborator being
pro-democracy
groups like the world and communist
league this is where this core of people
is involved in the world and our
communist league and uh which for a time
than
the uh international director of was
general singlab and it's
it's a hat that gets passed around he's
still active in it but this has some of
the most notorious uh
uh ex-nazis next fascists and death
squad leaders in the world a matter of
fact some of the right wingers
were bailing out of the world any
communist league because they said it
was too violent
well in fact one of the funniest memos
i've ever seen on the rural
anti-communist league is from a very
right-wing
uh british group that said we're very
conservative but these people are nazis
and we will not be part of it
and they also there are several other
studies done by european
former members who just said you know we
know the difference between being a
political conservative
and being an outright nazi and these
people are outright nazis they want a
fascist
authoritarian form of government uh to
fight communism because it's efficient
and it's true i mean you know fascism is
a very efficient form and if that's that
these people think that it's
perfectly legitimate to give up civil
liberties to stop their perception of
what
they see as communism i think it's
ironic that the
rural atlantic communist league and a
lot of other organizations which work
in conjunction with the israeli secret
police the mossad i was reading an
article where
somebody said hey how come you uh
anti-semites work with these
israelis they say well they're good jews
well you have to be careful here because
there's such a history of anti-semitism
in the world and in the country that you
have to pick your terms carefully
the great tragedy i think is that groups
like the anti-defamation league
which could expose people like laszlo
pastor
and could expose the fascist
anti-semitic character of many of the
members of the world dynamic communist
league
choose not to and i really think that
that's a that's a shame because
uh you would think that they would be in
the forefront of exposing these people
and they're not
they have a double standard actually in
adl they have one standard for black
democrats
and another standard for white
republicans so what i think the point
is to be careful to understand that
coalitions are formed
for political expediency and the same
people who would put jews to death in
the holocaust
will work with reactionary jews to fight
communism
and that may be i think i think it's
pretty dumb coalition because you know
if
as soon as they liquidate communism i'm
pretty sure they turn around and
liquidate their current allies
so it's a very short-sighted coalition
right let's focus on the world
anti-communist league in the reagan
administration
they came to some prominence in the
media during this
administration when singlaub and others
in this group came to support the
contras how did this happen and is this
sort of typical
of how some of these right-wing groups
are able to penetrate
the u.s government become part of
foreign policy invest
in adventures well i think it's a
question of penetration as much as
they're part of the political coalition
these days uh
you have to go back to the mccarthy
period to understand that there has
always been
a nativist core
that has gotten elected to congress and
that has some role in republican party
politics primarily
uh nativism is a political movement of
the 1800s which was xenophobic it feared
foreigners
feared immigrants thought that the they
had an idealized view of the american
way of life and this kind of theory
today has led to the kind of phobia
about perceived subversion and communism
and that's
the roots of it are in the nativist
movement so these reactionary nativist
circles
are there in the reagan administration
they helped elect reagan through the new
right and the religious right and some
of the
stop the sale of the panama canal single
issue groups
brought real reactionary mentality
people into the government
as a very normal process of paying them
back for their electoral support
the i think the best example to
understand how this functions is to see
how george schultz fared
during the early stages of the iran
contra affair george schultz is a
political conservative
he's not my hero as a politician but he
came under constant attack by the more
reactionary circles
because he had some allegiance to the
constitution
and they did not but that's really what
came down is that the more reactionary
circles in the in the white house and in
the executive branch and in congress
didn't like george schultz because he
was continually holding up the yardstick
of the constitution and saying
we can't really step over this line and
that gets us to what was really going on
with
bill casey and oliver north and these
people which is that they think they
know better they think that people who
aren't willing to use the tough
measures uh are wimps essentially and
are going to allow america to fall apart
and their patriotism is so jingoistic
and so
arcane that they think it's perfectly
logical
to destroy the constitution in order to
save america
because what they see is the
constitution and what they see as
america are two different things
i don't i mean i think i think our
society is based on a constitution
and that's the document that holds us
together they see an idealized
romanticized
primarily male white agrarian society
that they long for and that's what
they're trying to reconstruct in their
own mind when they violate the
constitution as they do and how did
singh lab and his world anti-communist
league
get into the reagan administration and
work with them on this contra project
primarily because of the same mechanism
that brought in
the the the nazi forces after world war
ii
is that you have this sort of unholy
alliance
of political fascism industrial
right-wing money
and government anti-communist structures
that developed this theory of the
permanent war with communism
and you see the theoretical writings of
this in the early 50s with the work of
of william kintner who actually wrote a
book called the front
is everywhere and the work of strauss
who pay
and others of the foreign policy
research institute at the university of
pennsylvania and
some work done at the hoover institute
where people lay out the idea that we
are in a struggle to death with
political communism
which in this country manifests itself
through subversion through social change
groups
and they actually develop a theory of
both foreign policy and domestic
repression which sees an unending
struggle of peeling back these layers
until you find the bolshevik core and
it's this mentality that is useful if
you're doing a counter-insurgency
program in vietnam
or in thailand or cambodia or in the
philippines or in central america or
africa
and so you have this alliance of forces
sometimes they operate with the
tacit approval of the government
sometimes they operate with the complete
approval of the government
sometimes they sort of do their own
thing and the government looks the other
way
and it's sort of a it's a loosely
structured network but it's one that has
some very serious agreements
around what needs to be done and the
necessity of
breaking a few eggs to make the omelet i
saw an article in covert action
information bulletin which
laid out the relationships of the
religious fundamentalist right wing
with this right-wing network which we're
talking about
and these religious fundamentalist
leaders
are intertwined with these various
organizations
you know the pat robinson group the
mooney groups causa or sia usa however
they pronounce
it okay they are members of the world
any communist league they
help them providing funds for the
contours they're in a lot of these
organizations
now is this are they closely allied or
are they intermixed completely or
they just work together for the same
cause
all of the above i mean it really
depends on the issue the specific issue
in the specific time period because they
have fights too i mean there's falling
outs
it's important to understand where the
new right comes from because the new
right
has become a major player in republican
party politics and in governing our
country
they're a factor that has to be dealt a
card at the table
you know when you sit down and divide up
they got to get something
they got to get a slice of the pie and
my premise has always been over the last
10 years is that why
do we use the most reactionary and
violent counter insurgency methods in
central america
and the answer simply is because there's
no market there and so if you're going
to have to give a slice of the pie to
some wacko right right-wing
reactionary you might as well give him a
country that has no economy
because the same reagan administration
that swore
to that to defend to the death the the
the barrier against communism in
nicaragua was opening up trade deals in
russia
and china then why was that allowed to
happen and the answer is
that you have to give them something and
you can give them undeveloped countries
that don't have
real markets that are definable to screw
out with and destroy
and then they're happy meanwhile the big
boys get to you know make billions uh
selling coke and
mcdonald's hamburgers so the new right
becomes a player and they did it very
cleverly by coming up with vertical
sectors to organize
they came up with knitting together
industrialists
investors and bankers people worried
about the collapse of morality in
christianity
people worried about communism people
worried about this that and the other
thing
all these single-issue sectors were put
together
with industrialist and investment
banking community
and presented a package that they could
all generally agree on
even though some of it's mutually
inconsistent like trade with russia
while stopping communism in nicaragua
which is less communist than russia was
at the time so
clearly this was a this is a brilliant
maneuver and it lasted for quite a while
it came out however of a political
organization that was put together by a
handful of people
who really came out of the
segregationist forces in the united
states
and really defined a classic reactionary
model
and there were people like howard
phillips richard vigory the direct mail
wizard
paul wyrick of the free congress
foundation wyrick who has always been
the emissary of the coors family money
in washington
and they approached jerry falwell to
create moral majority
and it's important to understand that
this was created by a group of people
with reactionary segregation
as a political or project project that's
right
you've always had religious
fundamentalism in this country and it
very often has not been
allied with political reaction it's been
conservative but it's not by all any
means been traditionally reactionary or
pro-fascist
um then you have money pouring in from
industrialists
uh such as smith richardson owen
foundation
the coors family milliken fabrics you
know the visa fabrics the people who
make that
they buy full page ad in john birch
society publications
uh the loctite corporation found a
former director of that is a mr kriebel
richard millen scafe of the mellon
family fortune
all of these old money industrial groups
and some of the new money investment
you know the yankees and the cowboys got
together on this and they funded
this entity which was a reactionary
entity
and it grew and it staked out a vote
that it could control
and it then went to the republican party
and said you got to deal us
in and they did and that's how this came
about and they gave them the cultural
war as their side absolutely
they couldn't give them abortion because
they tried and failed and they tried a
prayer in school and failed but they
could give something and it happened
unfortunately to be central america
and parts of africa that's tragic
there's another stratum of
u.s government that gets involved
interlaced all throughout these various
organizations
are direct and indirect connections with
the u.s intelligence services
particularly the cia can you tell us
about that
well that's that's a much larger area
but there's no doubt that it's true and
it again it goes back to that classic uh
deal with the devil i call it when we
decided to bring over
uh the uh the galen network after world
war ii
there is clearly a shared interest
in both religious fundamentalism that is
reactionary in character
in terms of anti-communism the
hyperbolic form
in terms of a number of these different
entities in terms of
the government uh counterinsurgency arm
wanting to defend it
america its view of america from its
perceived enemy
because the religious people don't like
communism because it's godless
the anti-communists don't like communism
because they're phobic about it
and the more mainstream political forces
in the government
don't like communism because it
restricts markets and they're the
kissingers of the world are
pragmatically
you know pragmatically and
programmatically against communism
because it defines markets that aren't
penetrable by u.s investment
so you have suddenly a group of people
all of whom find a common
purpose in working together and so they
do and you know i don't know how many
people grew up reading the books by tom
dooley
about his missions in china and all of
this stuff
but i certainly did i didn't read them
uh but you remember but you're always
hearing about the
saints these are these saint-like people
who set up these christian missions all
over the world
and if you go back now and look through
the files and through the documents and
through
some of the material that has come out
in fact many of these people were sent
there as
if not originally part of they were they
were adopted into counterinsurgency
efforts all over the world
cia operations uh which continued today
through a variety of religious front
groups whose
main goal may be on paper to help
refugees and to help the poor but who
are in fact part of counterinsurgency
operations a classic example
is a group called the christian
anti-communism crusade which does
revivals in the philippines revivalist
meetings
where they bring people back to christ
and general ramos of the philippines is
an active an
ardent supporter of of this and dr fred
schwartz is the guy who runs the
christian anti-communism crusade
and john whitehall is one of his chief
field workers
and when you go and see the materials
that are handed out
these are manuals and cartoon books
and documents talking about stopping the
spread of communism at its source
which is liberalism political liberalism
is defined
as where the slippery slope starts down
towards communism
well you know that's pretty scary stuff
to start talking about how you have to
fight political liberalism and secular
humanism is another code word
because it inevitably leads towards
barbaric terrorist communism
and that's actually the images they use
in the philippines but it produces death
squads
it produces death stars that's right it
motivates these people and guides them
to kill
supposed communist subversives didn't
this group take hold in guatemala rios
yes lot was a fundamentalist uh convert
to
this kind of religious line and he was
ruthless
in his use of death squads and
pacification camps
to exterminate sure because you had not
only political expediency
and economic pragmatism but you had the
zealotry of a religious crusade right
and that's what's the most scary part of
this kind of reactionary minded thinking
that adds on a religious element if you
understand the na
people in this country cannot define
fascism
and they cannot define nazism they have
a cartoon book
concept of what these are if you believe
that fascism and nazism existed during
world war ii
and when hitler died it was all over
it's because no one's taught you what
political fascism was as a movement
based on nationalism and no one taught
you that nazism
was political nationalistic fascism with
a race conscious theory applied over it
and that these are theories that anybody
can have that they're not
german they're not italian uh you can
understand the kind of reactionary
move in israel much more clearly if you
understand that it has nothing to do
with who you are where you come from
that's how you see the world
authoritarian mentality an authority
dualistic
mentality that sees enemies is
absolutely evil that's kind of threat
and sees yourself
as absolutely good and with a historic
mission right and
your enemy is so violent so vicious so
evil that you have to exterminate them
and you can use
anything you do is justified they
believe in
an authoritarian structure of society
in which the government has a right to
intervene not only in economic
relationships but in private personal
and religious relationships that
believes in a historical destiny
for the nation that it's involved in
that believes
that a strong leader who exerts
his will primarily deserves
unquestioning support
to fulfill that historic mission that
sees
the role of the worker is
to be a good worker and help build the
society and
not demand too much from the industrial
side
sees the industrialist role as working
in a partnership with the government
to move the nation forward with the
quiescence and support of the workforce
sees morality in very narrow terms that
are defined
to support a male primarily male
primarily white primarily had a
exclusively heterosexual except in the
case of the strasser
faction and they were dealt with neither
long knives and
essentially a rigid view of
dominance as being justified by god uh
if you're powerful enough to see his
power then by god you should run the
country as you see fit
it leads to violence because if your
destiny is to expand
your power and influence and any means
necessary
are legitimate you're going to have to
use violence in some cities
violence externally as well as
international right as well as
suppressing the enemy or threatening
this
fascist project because you're standing
in the way of destiny
therefore any means that are required to
quiet dissent or justified
and since your destiny is global you
then
treat borders as merely a temporal
impediment to your growth
historically let me just add that nazism
adds to that racial destiny
and it's important to understand that
nazism as an ism
doesn't think of particularly one group
as less important as much as it thinks
of itself as more important
it's important to understand also that
when mussolini was asked to define
fascism he said first and foremost you
must understand that
fascism is reactionary reactionary
though is another term that's
that's loose people don't understand
what reactionary means
reactionary politics fascist politics or
proto-fascist politics that's
reactionary
comes from a political movement against
modernity
which was the political theory of our
revolution and the french revolution
expounded by rousseau
and what were these theories that people
were
it was good to be equal before the law
equality not that everyone was the same
but you stood equal before the law
you know uh there's equality i can get
this one there's fraternity and
what was that liberty liberty liberty
civil liberty liberty from oppressive
government though they meant they didn't
just mean civil liberties as we know
them
but the right of people to petition for
change in government and not to be
oppressed
by an overarching government that
intruded itself into your daily life
that's what they meant by liberty and
fraternity in the sense that everyone
shared a spark of humanity that should
be defended
which flies in the face of the idea that
your enemy is evil and should be
exterminated
so reactionary politics which are now
dealt a card at the table of the
republican party
includes that force which does not
believe we are all equal before the law
that does not believe that the
government should keep its nose out of
everyone's business and not be
oppressive
and believe that certain people don't
deserve to live
and that's a scary thought but they
actually that's their political basis of
ideology they also don't believe in
liberties or rule by law this is another
function of the modern state to
establish rule by law
right and is precisely these rules by
law
that fascists and these reactionary
groups oppose because they think this is
an abstract liberalism
and that there's higher moral purposes
than mere positive law
and so that's why fascists easily broke
the law
to beat up on jews and then eventually
to exterminate them
because they didn't believe well
actually by law and these
groups also in the u.s really are
lawless what they actually did
it's interesting to note that first they
passed laws uh
to allow uh for confiscation so they did
two things at the same time first they
allowed the brown church to break the
law
and they simply let them beat people up
kristallnacht and in some of the street
fighting
and then when some people rej rejected
that
ham-handed brown shirtism they simply
passed laws to make the state do it so
it's important to understand it's a
one-two punch
you know in one hand the private right
wing goes out and does it
and if that isn't working popularly
enough then the state will come in and
do it and that they
they trade positions and power back and
forth in that way
which is a very normal way of a
political process of functioning but
it happens how many people and how many
organizations are we talking about now
the right way in the united states
fascist authoritarian stripe
well there are probably 200
organizations that we follow at
political research associates
and in those groups it's difficult to
say what they're following is because
they are higher
not surprisingly given their
authoritarian event they're hierarchical
they're they're organized from the top
down there's not a real grassroots
movement
across the board for this and they're
enter logs and their interlocks is
tremendous
board overlapping of the course funded
groups for instance
um so i i'd be hard-pressed to say
a fixed number i mean there's probably
fewer than
a hundred thousand activists in this
field
but they probably reach 10 to 20 million
americans
on some level on a weekly basis through
tv radio newspapers
and whether or not people buy the whole
package that they they are motivated
politically and
religiously by these forces and how
strong are they under bush we've noted
that under reagan they played a leading
role
in many projects in his administration
have they been shunted to the sideline
by the bush administration
or are they still players well this is
the one two punch they're still players
but they have lost power and in fact
there's a split within these groups
the people like richard vigory and
howard phillips called reagan
a useful idiot for even negotiating with
gorbachev
so that to a certain extent the most
extreme reactionary elements have been
broken away
from the the uh more mainstream of their
institutionalized reality so that you
have
the heritage foundation people being a
little more closer to reality
in washington than the vigory phillips
people but they
even within that construct they don't
have the power they did under reagan
they've lost
power and uh you see them trying to
regain the
direction that they had when they built
this coalition the coalition that put
reagan into office no longer exists on
the political right in this country
but you can't dismiss it as having power
it's just it's fractured right now and
it's looking around
for some new some way of mobilizing its
forces
um and i think you see that especially
like with the abortion
uh fanatics who are have sensed that
they've reached the plateau in terms of
people
uh supporting them and are turning to
more and more extreme tactics so you
have to be careful that
sometimes isolation breeds a kind of
resistance and a
fight back that that's very dangerous
you also see however that the classic
you know this private sector gets pushed
back bush the former director of the cia
has simply institutionalized bipartisan
counter-insurgency as the dominant
american foreign policy
it certainly was strong under reagan but
what reagan
couldn't do bush has achieved because
reagan's
jingoism was just a little too extreme
congress really
didn't tolerate some of his more
adventurous policies
did bush uses the intelligence apparatus
and
and counter-insurgency and actually
intervention
like the panama invasion more
effectively much more than reagan so he
doesn't need to go outside
of established foreign policy
intelligence circles he knows that in
washington
whereas reagan was forced to bring in
some of these real extremists
from the right simply because he
couldn't get congress couldn't get
congress to go along with some of these
uh policies on the record
right but the extremists still are
working in conjunction with
with oh yes very much church
who's getting funds for hungarian groups
how do you see this in historical
perspective now we've been talking about
the republicans
and uh this implies if the democrats
were in this would no longer be the case
but we've seen the democrats
democrats have used repression that
means the democrats carried on the
vietnam war
most of the years we've seen
the fbi flourish under the democrats but
where if the democrats got elected where
would this right-wing uh
network go well they do what they always
do when democrats gain electoral power
which is that they fade back into think
tanks and
road shows and lectures at
american legion halls and begin writing
more vociferously in reader's digest
if you want to get a sense of where the
the
nexus with mainstream america is of this
reactionary
reality is go to your public library and
pick out articles and readers digest
that talk about
communism and liberalism and you know
teenage pregnancy and
it's a very reactionary kind of
worldview that's presented by them
but you also see them moving into uh
popular organizations now
for instance the coalition that's put
together by robert grant of christian
voice
and and the moon network american
freedom coalition
which puts out american freedom journal
which has offices in every state in the
united states and does
work on every state legislature and you
see them building
trying to build a grassroots movement
now that will get the kind of voting
power that they
they welded together when they first put
together the new right
back in the in the late 70s so i think
you have to look carefully at
groups like the american freedom
coalition and the moonies which are kind
of a theocratic fascist movement and
it's really
drives me wild when the people who want
to defend moon civil liberties and i
agree
his civil liberties are as valuable as
everyone else's but if you defend his
civil liberties i think it's important
to call him what he is he's a fascist
he is a classic theocratic fascist and
any textbook definition will suffice
if you look at what he says and what he
does and i i'm very upset by people who
don't use these terms because they're
afraid people will misunderstand them
i went up and saw george seldi's i go up
every year to see him uh a man who lives
with him
a man who's written 30 books on
political fascism and repression and
and authoritarianism and uh he just
shakes his head because he looks at
people like lyndon larouche and
and moon and some of these other groups
and say well how can you not call them
fascists given their
economic and political views it's just
there for anyone to see
and the answer is because we don't teach
that
fascism and authoritarianism and
political reaction
are ideologies that exist anymore
there's communism and there's democracy
and that's it in the world right what
how do you put this uh these
organizations and groups people we've
been talking about in historical
perspective
well the seeds for this kind of again
nativist reactionary
the politics of fear it's sometimes
called it reacts against what's
happening with fear and
seeks to find scapegoats the seeds are
always there there always are going to
be a handful of people around
professor richard hofstetter did a
classic study called the paranoid style
in american politics
and what he says is that these people
are always there as background noise
and in different periods of america
you've had them gain a mass following
and what he says is important to look at
is
why at any given period do these people
gain a mass following
and sometimes it's economic conditions
are bad and people are worried
sometimes their social conditions are
bad or there's
upheaval in the social construct
sometimes it has to do with
political battles and i think in what
we've seen
in most recently is with the rise of the
new right
it was a reaction against the 60s there
was a tremendous
flowering you'll find the firm of
political viewpoints and progressive
thinking and
challenges to the norm in terms of
sexuality and
uh in terms of politics and foreign
policy
and it galvanized a core group of people
who were afraid that america was
collapsing
and they first tried as early as 1964
to throw their weight behind goldwater
and that really didn't succeed for a
couple reasons
one of which goldwater was never as
extreme as they were you know he really
was more conservative than a reactionary
and so he never really was comfortable
with them and they were never
comfortable with him
uh after the goldwater campaign is when
you have vigory decide he's going to
re-grow
the american reactionary movement
without its ties to the old
segregationist birch past
and he does he succeeds and i think a
lot of the people who followed the new
right
felt that they didn't know where their
place was in the world
where america was place was america was
losing its status as a world power
they were losing their status as the
middle class their children
they suddenly felt maybe their children
wouldn't do as well as they did where
they did is better their their parents
life was to make their life better for
them and they couldn't do that for their
own children you know that hurts
that really hurts a parent i'm a parent
and i'm going you know i don't think
that
my son is going to have as good an
economic life as i do
and i certainly don't have as good an
economic life as my dad raised me under
so people who are scared like that
turn toward easy answers and that's kind
of scapegoating that goes on and you see
that in the rise of homophobia
especially and you see that in the rise
of anti-semitism and racism
that people who don't know where their
places in the world want to find an easy
scapegoat
and that's i think what we have seen is
the politics of scapegoating
and whether on foreign policy you're
scapegoating your perception of
communism as an evil
or terrorism or now drugs
you know this whole question of drugs
being aimed at the black community
when 80 percent of all drug abuse is in
the white community
there's something very sinister going on
there the statistics show very clearly
that drug abuse is a widespread problem
throughout our society
so it's scapegoating again and it serves
a very authoritarian function
well it looks like it might get worse
because the economic system is
unraveling our society seems to be
unraveling compared to
like you say compared to previous
generations so is there a danger of this
becoming much worse sure there's always
a danger it could get much worse there's
also a possibility that
you know you see the college kids on
campuses today a lot of them are getting
active in a lot of levels
you also see this splitting up as some
previous givens
for instance even among the reactionary
right you have more and more people
concerned about environmentalism
and and that's good that's very positive
and i think that that you're going to
see environmentalism crossing a lot of
these sectors
and breaking down a coalition that has
existed in the past
and that will that will help you also
see more and more people
coming to grips with women in society
it's not perfect but it's better and
people feel better about it they're less
awkward
and there's a tension there that hasn't
gone away but it seems to be resolving i
mean society seems to now
be ready to accept that women deserve
equal status
they haven't gotten around to providing
it yet uh i would say
it's not a thing as the collapse of the
soviet empire
no longer provides the sort of real
justification for anti-communism in
other words the soviet union was
expansionist
yeah for many years it did pose a threat
to u.s interests in different parts
geographically sure yeah and this is no
longer the case right so there's not
any rational facade for anti-communism
of the sort that's been the dominant
religion right in this country and this
i think is going to hurt those
right-wing groups
i agree i was going to say that in terms
of foreign policy that clearly is the
major thing
uh historic typical kind of right
transition well they'll take
something like that drugs and terrorism
will do
gays they've already begun to target
i think you have to understand that also
that with the attacks especially there's
a there's a rise in anti-semitism but
the rise of racism is very troubling
because we have yet to set an agenda
where we deal with that on a national
level and
you really have to understand that
that's the most unfinished agenda of all
of these
issues